hey what is up guys mkbhd here and good
news for anyone who owns a samsung
galaxy s6 or galaxy s6 edge or was
thinking about buying one samsung has
approved a material design theme in
their theme store right now and it's
live one of my personal biggest
complaints with this contender for one
of the best phones of 2015 is still the
software and yes it is a market
improvement from the galaxy s5 last year
there's a lot less bloatware a lot less
unnecessary crap but it's still
definitely touchwiz and i still
definitely prefer a cleaner look from
something like a nexus over that and i'm
not the only one so this approval of a
material design theme is a pretty big
deal so to find it first of all it's not
in the new section of the theme store
which is where you'd expect to find it
instead it's under the themes for man
section what why is it called that
i don't really know so once you find it
you can download it and apply it and
it's free and boom you've got it
installed now like any theme from the
store it changes a lot of the elements
of the look of your phone now because of
copyrights it's not exactly the same as
a nexus it doesn't look exactly like
what you would find on a nexus 6 and
anyone can put them side by side and
observe that but it's sort of like a
hybrid in that way and it's unique and i
kind of like it it has a lot of the
elements of both samsung's features and
stock android's look so jumping in the
overall look of course of samsung
software is changed so the lock screen
first of all looks a bit more flat with
the shortcuts in each corner and then
it's given that material design
wallpaper and the colors aren't exactly
right but it's still close enough and
then jumping in you can see the app
drawer has the skin and all the icons
are skinned and even the quick settings
pull down is themed to look a lot more
like that material dark theme you'd find
on a nexus but it still keeps all of
samsung's functionality all the buttons
are still the same and the settings app
i think is actually the best improvement
or at least the one that looks closest
to what i'd find in a nexus with all the
simplified icons and all the colors it
looks way better in my opinion than the
sort of cartoonish set we had before so
settings i give a great thumbs up to and
then there's all the other stock apps
that we themed
the dialer again this isn't a perfectly
themed skin but it's somewhat close and
the messenger app also so it's much more
material here
although you can totally get the google
messenger itself from the play store now
so you can see the samsung keyboard here
which not only looks a lot like the
stock lollipop one but i actually think
it's better with the permanent number
keys up top but maybe that's just me you
also get a skinned calculator which
looks a bit better and you also get a
skinned clock but also again the stock
clock from android is available in the
play store as well so that's recent you
can grab that if you want that more
authentic look but you can also get this
skinned calendar app and a skinned email
app i mean a ton of the stock apps are
skinned in this theme here and it looks
pretty complete as far as touchwiz stuff
goes so i'm a big fan of this and
obviously if you want to take it to the
next level of authenticity or looking a
lot more like a nexus then you can
install actual google apps from the play
store to replace the ones on the phone
so i did that with like the google
messenger and the google clock and
actually even the google launcher
although you don't get all the custom
icons if you use the google now launcher
but i'm fine with that so there you go i
was inspired to make the video about
this because this is about as close as
it's going to get now to my version of a
dream phone which would be a google play
edition galaxy s6 edge but that's
obviously not gonna happen but it's
really all about aesthetics uh this is
about as close as it's gonna get because
you're not gonna be able to match
functionality of android l and android m
with all the stuff you get with touchwiz
even though these features are nice
they're not as pretty so the theme sort
of makes that better so there you have
it uh if you enjoyed it feel free to
give this video a thumbs up and if you
want to see more videos sort of like
this then leave a thumbs up or a comment
down below to let me know either way
that's been it thanks for watching and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace